hallo und willkommen zu heute live es
ist ein Tag von hoher Symbolik und der
Mittelpunkt dabei steht die Rhetorik
denn es geht um das Fernduell der
Präsidenten US-Präsident beiden
antwortet auf die Rede von russlands
Präsident Putin zum ukrainekrieg und
eine der Fragen ist was verraten denn
diese Reden über die jeweiligen Redner
und über ihre Pläne und Absichten damit
wollen wir uns heute beschäftigen eure
Fragen und Kommentare gerne wieder bei
uns an Mail oder an uns per Mail besser
gesagt oder über Social Media und Putin
der hat den Aufschlag gemacht der
bereits am Vormittag gesprochen darauf
gehen wir dann gleich ausführlicher ein
vorher aber wollen wir uns mit dem
zweiten Redner mit US-Präsident beiden
beschäftigen der war gestern Abend ja
überraschend in Kiew erst gewesen dann
allerdings am Abend schon weiter gereist
nach Warschau wo heute nach dem Empfang
durch Staatspräsident Du da in wenigen
Minuten dann eben auch eine mit große
Spannung erwartete Rede und zwar im
Warschauer Schloss halten wird das dann
gleich der Schwerpunkt bei uns diese
Rede vor Ort verfolgen wird für uns Elma
teven den ich an dieser Stelle wenn wir
ihnen denn dann gleich schon sehen auch
ganz herzlich begrüßen möchte da ist er
Elmar schön dass du bei uns bist was ist
da heute in Warschau vom US-Präsidenten
zu erwarten
ja neben Christopher er will eine große
Rede halten das hat man uns hier vorher
gesagt und das bedeutet er will ein Jahr
nach Kriegsbeginn ein Stück weit Bilanz
ziehen und sehr klar machen dass
Vladimir putinsplan nicht aufgegangen
ist und dass die USA alles daran setzen
werden um zu verhindern dass dieser Plan
tatsächlich am Ende noch erfüllt werden
kann die USA werden der ja keine
weiterhin helfen mit allem was Sie
können es ist möglich dass der Präsident
hier oder vielleicht in den nächsten
Tagen auch ankündigen wird dass die
keine weitreichende Raketen bekommen
soll das wäre eine sehr wichtige
Ankündigung weil damit wäre die Ukraine
in der Lage da möglicherweise auch die
Nachschubwege für die russischen
Streitkräfte auf der Krim zu
unterbrechen das hier ist gewissermaßen
eine Art Heimspiel für Joe Biden weil
hier 82% der Polen der Meinung sind dass
er das Richtige tun wird die USA gelten
als verlässlicher Partner im Grunde
genommen als Sicherheitsgarantie für
Polen und beiden wir hier ein Signal
senden an Moskau das Putin eben diesen
Krieg nicht gewinnen kann und dass er an
einen Punkt gebracht wird bei dem er
sieht dass das größere Interesse
Russlands wäre sich an den
Verhandlungstisch zu setzen so weit sind
wir nicht jetzt spricht hier der
polnische Präsident du da gerade und
gleich wird dann eben in einigen Minuten
auch Joe Biden erwartet vielen Dank
Elmar für diese ersten Eindrücke und
Einschätzung wir schalten dann später im
Stream noch mal zu dir zurückschauen
jetzt aber erstmal auf die Rede von
Vladimir Putin die er am Vormittag in
Moskau gehalten hat und Nina lieber geil
hat das wichtigste für uns noch mal
zusammengefasst
sie war mit Spannung erwartet worden
Putins jahresbotschaft an Russland
welche Richtung würde er vorgeben was
dann folgte war vor allem mein best of
russischer Propaganda eine Abrechnung
mit dem Westen
ich sage es noch einmal sie haben diesen
Krieg angefangen wir haben nur Gewalt
genutzt und tun das immer noch um ihn zu
stoppen
russland habe den Konflikt mit der
Ukraine friedlich lösen wollen der
Westen sei voll verantwortlich so Putin
auch für alle wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen Probleme im Land die der
russische Präsident ohnehin für kaum
[Applaus]
existentoren von Sanktionen bestrafen
sich selbst sie haben Inflation
Arbeitslosigkeit und energiekrisen in
ihren eigenen Ländern provoziert
es sind Erzählungen die man aus Putins
reden kennt und die Russen wohl vor
allem auf einen langen Krieg einstimmen
sollen kurz vor Ende lässt Putin dann
doch noch eine politische Bombe platzen
sie wollen uns eine strategische
Niederlage zufügen und unsere
nuklear-anlagen bezwingen ich bin
deshalb gezwungen heute bekannt zu geben
dass Russland seine Teilnahme an dem
Vertrag über strategische Offensivwaffen
aussetzt damit ist der letzte
verbliebene atomwaffenkontrollvertrag
mit den USA gemeint
[Applaus]
ja und jetzt ist die Autorin des
Beitrags bei mir im Studio sie ist
bereits seit einem knappen halben Jahr
fürs ZDF als Russland Korrespondentin
tätig wartet aber derzeit noch auf ihre
Arbeitserlaubnis für Russland und ist
daher noch in Deutschland gut für uns
schön dass du da bist Nina lieber geil
welchen Eindruck hat Putins Rede bei dir
hinterlassen
ja man wusste
ja fragen würde es konnte also nur
spekulieren und da fahren tatsächlich
viele Stadt Leute haben befürchtet oder
haben damit gerechnet dass er vielleicht
eine neue mobilisierungswelle ankündigen
würde dass er vielleicht die Wirtschaft
auf Kriegswirtschaft umstellen würde
oder dass er offiziell den Krieger
klären würde vielleicht sogar das waren
die düstersten Prognosen an die Nato und
all das ist ähm bekanntermaßen jetzt
nicht eingetreten sondern er hat viel
wiederholt der Erzählung und der Drogen
die wir auch schon in der Vergangenheit
das vergangenen reden von ihm kennen
nämlich dass der Westen der Adresse ist
das Russland sich nur verteidigt das
sind hier ein Marionetten Regime
installiert ist also das war ähm das
waren eher die bekannteren Generation
sozusagen neu waren aus meiner Sicht
zwei Dinge nämlich einmal dass er eben
den letzten verbliebenen Atomwaffen
kontrollvertrag mit den USA ausgesetzt
hat das haben wir einen Beitrag gehört
und zweitens es wirkte so ein bisschen
wie ein Detail aber er sagte
das Soldaten die in der Ukraine im
Einsatz sind alle sechs Monate Urlaub
machen können und das deutet natürlich
darauf hin dass er mit einem langen
Krieg rechnet und dass er auch die
Russen auf dem langen Krieg einschwören
möchte ja also ihr denkt da offenbar
tatsächlich in längeren Zeit Horizonten
es ist ja auch heute so eine Art
Wettkampf der Symbolik man könnte auch
sagen der PR ähm wer schneidet da für
dich stand jetzt besser ab Putin oder
beiden ja der Wettkampf gegen ja gestern
schon los als beiden nach Kiew gereist
ist das hat natürlich starke Bilder
produziert und das wurde auch in
russischen Talkshows im Staatsfernsehen
besprochen von den Chef Propagandisten
sozusagen und die haben das so ein
bisschen dargestellt als sei beiden
endlich nach nach Kiew gereist endlich
in die Ukraine gereist und das auch nur
weil Russland Sicherheitsgarantien
gegeben hätte also sie haben das so ein
bisschen ja in ihrer in ihrem Sinne
dargestellt und das soll aber natürlich
darüber hinweg täuschen das Putin noch
nicht in die besetzten Gebiete gereist
ist obwohl das durchaus immer wieder im
Gespräch war und so blieb heute
natürlich in Moskau eine
Pflichtveranstaltung die im vertrauten
Rahmen stattfand und die keine
Überraschungen bereit hielt und keine
besonders starken Bilder produziert hat
andere Aspekt russland hat offenbar
Pläne für eine schrittweise Übernahme
seines Nachbarlandes Belarus bis 2030
ich skizziere das ganz kurz das geht aus
einem Dokument aus dem Kreml hervor das
mehrere deutsche Medien ausgewertet
haben westliche Geheimdienste halten
dieses Papier das aus dem Sommer 2021
stammen soll für authentisch
demzufolgeplant Präsident Putin bellaros
politisch wirtschaftlich und militärisch
zu unterwandern ziel ist es das Land bis
2030 zu einem unionstaat unter
russischer Führung zu machen
wir sind für dich diese Pläne
einzuschätzen ja kurz zur Einordnung
diesen Unionsstaat Belarus Russland den
gibt es schon seit 2000 man kann sich
das so ein kleines bisschen vorstellen
wie die Europäische Union es sollen
Gemeinschaft gemeinsam Wirtschaftsraum
geben eine koordinierte Außenpolitik und
Russland hat ja auch Truppen und auch
Waffen in Belarus stationiert aber
Lukaschenko hat in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder betont und hat das auch
gestern noch mal bekräftigt dass er
weiter an der Souveränität von Belarus
festhalten möchte und dass sich
belarussische Truppen durchaus wären
würden auf eine ukrainische Aggression
also wenn ukrainische Truppen auf
belarussische Territorium kommen würden
dann würde sich die belarussische Armee
wären aber das ist natürlich ja eine
sehr vorsichtige Einschränkung sozusagen
und so lange wie gesagt möchte er da
eher souverän bleiben in dieser Sache
Einsatz noch dazu Lukaschenko ist
natürlich abhängig von Putin
vor allem seit 2020 wer sich an die
Proteste erinnert da hat Putin geholfen
die Proteste niederzuschlagen also da
steht Lukaschenko so ein kleines
bisschen in seiner Schuld aber in der
Vergangenheit ist es ihm immer wieder
gelungen seine Souveränität bzw die
Souveränität von Belarus zu behaupten
und es wäre auch glaube ich den
Belarussen schwer zu vermitteln wenn
Belarus in einem Einheitsstaat mit
Russland komplett aufgehen würde
soweit die Einschätzungen von Nina
Niebergall unserer Russland
Korrespondentin noch in Deutschland
demnächsten hoffentlich dann auch in
Moskau danke schön dafür und wir gehen
einen Schritt weiter Putin hat in seiner
Rede außerdem die Aussetzung des
atomaren abrüstungsvertrages new Starts
mit den USA angekündigt Russland so
Putin müsse bereits sein Atomwaffentests
wieder aufzunehmen sollten die USA dies
tun was dieser Schritt jetzt bedeutet
und
genau welche Folgen das nach sich ziehen
könnte darüber sprechen wir gleich mit
dem Politikwissenschaftler Maximilian
Terhalle vorher klärt uns mein Kollege
Christian Volk noch mal darüber auf was
ist mit diesem new startvertrag genau
auf sich hat
die USA und Russland besitzen 90 Prozent
aller Atomwaffen auf der Welt deshalb
sind ihre Verträge zentral bei der
atomaren Abrüstung vor 1987 bis 2019
galt der INF-Vertrag zur Reduzierung von
Atomwaffen mit kürzerer und mittlerer
Reichweite bis die USA ausstiegen es
blieb nur noch das new start-abkommen
von 2011 der Vertrag begrenzt wie viele
atomspringen Köpfe mit großer Reichweite
die Länder stationiert haben dürfen
außerdem erlaubt der beiden Ländern
Kontrollbesuche vor Ort allerdings gab
es bereits seit März 2020 keine
Inspektion mehr zuerst wegen Corona
später sperrte sich Russland dann gegen
die us-kontrollen weil Washington
angeblich Russland den Zutritt zu
bestimmten Anlagen verweigert habe die
USA bestreiten das nun könnte eine
weitere Eskalation Folgen Putin rief
heute das Militär auf sich für
Atomwaffentests bereit zu halten falls
Washington solche Tests zuerst ausführen
sollte
tja und darüber sprechen wir nun mit
Maximilian Terhalle er ist
Politikwissenschaftler an der London
School of Economics and political
science und jetzt allerdings
zugeschaltet aus Berlin einen schönen
guten Tag guten Tag hätte Halle was
bedeutet die Aussetzung dieses Vertrags
jetzt durch Putin
ja das ist ein
starker machtpolitischer Auftritt den
Putin hier sucht er will die Botschaft
erstens senden das Russland ein nicht zu
unterschätzender nuklearfaktor in der
Welt ist er will die Bestrebungen die ja
ganz klar im Gange sind die Ukraine
seitens des Westens drastisch zu
unterstützen panzerlieferung etc dem
will er jetzt ein Signal entgegensetzen
ihr spielt hier mit dem Feuer das hat er
ja schon mehrfach gemacht letztes Jahr
auch die deutschen Panzerlieferungen
sind deshalb lange gescheitert er will
Drohung aussprechen dass er im besitzen
ist und damit gleichzeitig sagen dass
man die auch nutzen kann wir haben
letztes Jahr gesehen dass das hier zu
Eskalation kurz das Relation kam am Ende
September Oktober ist zwischen
Amerikanern Gespräche geführt worden
nach dem Putin angedeutet hatte er würde
taktische Nuklearwaffen nutzen ich
glaube dass ein in der Hinsicht ist das
betrachten die Erneuerung dieser
einschichterungs Machtpolitik die Putin
hier betreibt um die gegenwärtigen
Waffenlieferungen die geplant sind zu
unterlaufen und vielleicht doch das ein
odere Land andere Land innerhalb der
NATO hier zu einer anderen Entscheidung
zu bringen wir warten auf die Rede des
US-Präsidenten Herr Thale nutzen die
Zeit natürlich gerne um noch mit ihnen
ein bisschen weiter auch über die
russische Seite zu sprechen da gibt es
offenbar eine andere Art der das der
Eskalation derzeit innerhalb der
russischen Streitkräfte nämlich die
berüchtigten Söldner der Kampftruppe
Wagner die fühlen sich vom
Verteidigungsministerium unter
ministerschule gut verraten gehören den
Chef der Wagner Truppe im Odenkirchen
der Chef des Generalstabs und der
Verteidigungsminister erteilen einen
Befehl nach dem anderen der die
Lieferung von Munition an die
wagnertruppe und die Unterstützung beim
Lufttransport verbietet gerade kam die
Information herein dass sie den Antrag
auf die Ausgabe von pionierschaufeln
gestrichen haben damit die Jungs sich
nicht eingraben können es gibt einfach
eine direkte Opposition die nichts
anderes ist als ein Versuch die
wagnertruppe zu zerstören das kann mit
Hochverrat gleichgesetzt werden jetzt wo
Wagner und bachmut kämpft und jeden Tag
hunderte ihrer Kämpfer verliert
der erreicht uns gerade noch einen
Kommentar von JT Jehle lasst euch nicht
spalten wir sind alles Menschen Bürger
aus Russland USA und Ukraine wir wollen
alle keinen Krieg wenn es so einfach
wäre wäre das ja schön aber zurück zu
dem was wir gerade gehört haben Herr
Halle wie würden Sie diese Spannung auf
Seiten der Russen bewerten ja das ist
natürlich von der aus der Sicht der
Ukrainer ist das natürlich eine
willkommene Äußerung der inneren
Schwäche des
Apparates des militärapparates der
Russen also wir sehen das tut natürlich
regulären Truppen im Dienst hat an der
Front aber eben wesentlich auch die
wagnertruppe so das ist etwas das
versucht er zu koordinieren er versucht
diese wagnertruppe insbesondere durch
die Strafgefangenen der massenweise
eingebracht hat hier als Speerspitze zu
nutzen in der Koordination zwischen
regulären und nicht regulieren oder
Wagner Truppen scheint es erhebliche
Reibung zu geben das sehen sie eben an
der Kampfkraft gegenwärtig
alle haben die Russen ungefähr gerade in
der Schlacht im bachmut von bis zu 800
Toten im Augenblick das ist im Vergleich
zu der Schlacht im letzten Sommer Mai
Juni Zero renets Johannes nur 200 das
heißt die Koordinierung des
militärapparats die wird durch das
Einbringen der wagnergruppe eben nicht
vereinfacht die Schlagkraft wird nicht
zwingend erhöht deshalb kämpft diese
gewaltige Truppe aus Wagner und
regulärentruppen jetzt schon so lange an
bachmut und aus rheinischer Sicht beißen
Sie sich hier die Zähne aus wie gesagt
wir warten auf die Rede des
US-Präsidenten die jeden Moment losgehen
kann dann schaltet man natürlich direkt
dorthin welche Erwartungen haben sie an
diese Ansprache
naja ich glaube dadurch das Wichtigste
ist dass der US-Präsident zunächst in
Kiew war also in dem Land in dem Krieg
geführt hat während wir haben es vorher
gehört der russische Präsident bis heute
das nicht gewagt hat auf ukrainisches
Gebiet vorzugehen und dort eine Rede zu
halten jetzt ist er in Moskau in
Warschau haben und wird dort glaube ich
zwei Dinge mindestens noch mal
unterstreichen die Einheit des Westens
um die ist ja leider mir Putin seit
Anfang des Krieges geht die zu spalten
damit der Gegner schwächer wird das ist
nicht gelungen und gleichzeitig hat der
von ihm ja sogenannte dekadente Westen
bisher eben doch seine
Durchhaltefähigkeit in den
Waffenlieferungen in der humanitären
Hilfe
erhalten und das sind zwei Dinge die
wird Putin glaube ich die wird
beiden sehr deutlich in den Mittelpunkt
stellen um klar zu machen unsere
Botschaft ist Standfestigkeit
ich was Putin tut und wir sind hier
Amerika insbesondere mit 10.000 Mann ja
schon in der in Polen stationiert wir
sind eine Macht die hier nicht
zurückweichen wird und das sendet gerade
zu den Alliierten natürlich ein
vertrauensvolles aber auch ein
glaubwürdiges Signal der eigenen stärker
aus etwas was von vielen Seiten
bezweifelt worden ist aber einmal mehr
durch den Besuch glaube ich
unterstrichen wird dass es eben nicht
der Fall ist
King schreibt uns über Youtube ja ich
habe eine Frage wann hat der Wahnsinn
ein Ende gut jetzt muss man sagen die
ist dann eher rhetorischer Natur das
können wir alle leider nicht beantworten
wir hoffen sobald es möglich ist reden
wir noch mal kurz über die Ansprache des
russischen Präsidenten sie haben gerade
gesagt der US-Präsident setzt ein
starkes Zeichen aber auch russlands
Präsident Putin hat ja heute keinerlei
Anstalten gemacht irgendwie
zurückzuweichen wir haben sie seine Rede
insgesamt aufgefasst ja also ich habe
das
weitestgehend gefolgt sehr viele Muster
der Begründung des Krieges die auch
schon vorher genutzt hat aber eines
fehlt doch ganz offensichtlich nämlich
die
siegesbotschaft wo sind die großen
Erfolge die jetzt die russische Nation
weiterhin antreiben sollen um diesen
Krieg zu gewinnen der er aus russischer
sich gewonnen werden muss also dieser
erfolgsnachrichten die sind in keiner
Weise vorhanden wo sollten Sie auch
herkommen ich glaube das heißt ihn am
meisten wir hatten es gerade an der
Stadt bachmut ein kleiner Ort in dem die
Russen sich tatsächlich die Zähne
ausbeißen das ist das was in dieser Rede
durchweg fehlt weil es nicht existiert
und deshalb vielleicht auch erklärbar
das ganz zum Schluss noch einmal die
nukleare Variante hier gespielt wird in
sehr drastischer Form dürfen nicht
vergessen dass das der letzte
vertragliche Übereinkunft ist zwischen
Amerikanern und Russen über strategische
Nuklearwaffen Nuklearwaffen die
Kontinent weit über den Atlantik nach
Russland geschossen werden können die
vielleicht das ein Punkt der vielleicht
auch wichtig ist auch für die Jüngeren
Zuhörer nicht bei diesem kontinentalen
strategischen Waffen die sind dafür da
dass Europa von der Abschreckung
Amerikas profitiert das ist die zentrale
Wirkung dieser Waffen und ihn über diese
Waffen hat jetzt eine Seite hier Putin
gesagt diese Waffen möchte ich bei der
Form mehr beschränkt sehen das ist also
sehr bemerkenswert ich glaube aber dass
die Fähigkeit zu der sogenannten
Eskalation bei Putin daran gesehen wird
ich setze das einmal mehr als
Einschüchterung als Drohung in den Raum
um zu unterstreichen ich könnte auch
nuklear agieren wir wissen dass vieles
davon in nicht glaubwürdig ist
ja nachdenklich stimmt es ein dennoch
big Edge fragt uns was sagt denn China
zum Einfrieren des Atom
Abrüstungsvertrag das hatte ich hier
nicht bereits ein eine atomare
Eskalation stark verurteilt also die
Frage vielleicht auch danach inwieweit
China sich hier zum Mittler eventuell
doch noch mal aufschwingen könnte sehen
Sie denn dass China daran ein Interesse
hätte
china hat daran überhaupt gar keine
Interesse jeder will auf Augenhöhe
nuklear kommen wie die Vereinigten
Staaten deshalb hat es überhaupt gar
kein Interesse daran das ist eine
Vertrag hier Regelung gibt in die z.B
China mit eingeschlossen wurde z.B in
ein Startup kommen
so dass hier ich chinesische
Vermittlungs bemühen also in keiner
Weise
in Betracht zu ziehen sind oder dass die
wesentlicher glaubwürdige Natur haben
das Gegenteil soll von den Chinesen
erreicht werden aus ihrer Sicht
wir nutzen die Zeit wir warten immer
noch auf die Rede des US-Präsidenten wie
gesagt sollte eigentlich um 17 Uhr 30
soweit sein es wird sich wohl doch noch
um einige Minuten verzögern aber wir
sind sehr froh dass wir sie haben um
hier ein paar Fragen noch unsere
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen bzw unser
Userin und User zu beantworten so z.B
von Wolfgang Mücke der fragt wird Wagner
gemeint sind also sie hatten vorhin
schon drüber gesprochen die Wagner
Söldnertruppe werden die Putin zu stark
könnte das einen Faktor sein
naja Putin hat ein Ziel er will den
Krieg gewinnen und dafür nimmt er alles
was er finden kann wir haben es ja
gesehen wie massenweise Strafgefangene
rekrutiert wurden genau die
Strafgefangenen die jetzt den höchsten
Blut soll
ein erleben müssen
die Schwierigkeit die herrscht ist das
Putin direkt in die strategische
Kriegsführung eingreift und er hat hier
zu wenig berücksichtigt dass in diesem
brutalen Krieg diesen brutalen
Häuserkampf der geführt wird diese
wagnergruppe je nach Erfolg oder nicht
Erfolg natürlich gegenüber der regulären
Armeeführung Ansprüche erhebt
und das geht vor allem dieser Anspruch
dahin wie dieser Krieg geführt werden
soll und dann natürlich auch die
Honorierung der jeweiligen Erfolge
bisher gelingt diese Koordinierung
dieser beiden Armeeteile irregulär
regulär der gelingt wohl nicht ganz
ideal und dadurch kommt die Reibung
zustande und vielleicht dass das letzten
Punkt Wagner wurde lange natürlich auch
propagandistisch gut vorangebracht als
eine brutale
Einheit die für den Sieg stünde auch
diese brutale Einheit die sehr hoch
gelobt wurde tut sich enorm schwer gegen
die ukrainischen Verteidiger die ihre
natürlich deutlich besser kennen als der
Angreifer
Jonas m schreibt uns über Youtube geht
aktuell von Belarus noch eine Gefahr aus
wie lange kann deren Präsident zu Putin
nein sagen gut da könnte man vielleicht
jetzt auch noch mal gerade das mit
einbeziehen was vorhin mit Nina
niedergeist schon auch besprochen haben
dass es eben Pläne eine Annexion auch
gibt sozusagen oder zumindest eines
gemeinsamen unionsstaates unter
russischer Führung also wie sehen sie
diesen Aspekt Belarus Russland
ja
natürlich möchte Putin gerne dass ich
Belarus freiwillig am besten an die
frische Föderation anschließt
militärstrategisch sehe ich das nicht
als wahrscheinlich Russland kämpft mit
aller Kraft damit es überhaupt die Front
die Sie zum Beispiel
im Don Bass versuchen zu halten oder zum
Beispiel in Eroberung von bachmut
deutlich zu machen überhaupt das
militärisch leisten zu können so dass
ich das was jetzt gesagt wird das von
Belarus ausgegebenen falls eine
Initiative ein Angriff ausgehen könnte
in meinen Augen ist das wenig
geschicktes Büro Potenzial um die
Ukraine natürlich zu verunsichern wo sie
ihre Kräfte zentrieren sollen
nachdem was wir bisher sehen und ich
habe vorher angesprochen gegenwärtig
haben sie die Russen 8 bis 800
Tote in den gegenwärtigen kämpfen werden
sie vor einem halben Jahr nur tote pro
Tag hatten nur in Anführungsstrichen
also diese koalitionsfähigkeit die
Schlagkraft dafür reicht die
Militärorganisation der Russen nicht aus
jetzt eine neue Front aufzumachen
insofern würde ich hier eher sagen von
dort besteht keine unmittelbare Gefahr
ja der Halle vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung bis hierhin jetzt höre ich
gerade das so als Präsident beiden in
diesem Momenten vor die Kameras und
Mikrofone tritt um seine
Sprache seine genau seine Rede zu halten
die mit Spannung erwartet wird wir gehen
nach Warschau zum Schloss dort und zu
Präsident bleiben
Hamburger Meister verehrte Ex Minister
und Ministerin Bürgermeister aus
polnischen Städten vielen Dank dass Sie
mich wieder willkommen heißen hier in
Polen es ist jetzt schon fast ein Jahr
her dass ich hier vor dem König Schloss
in Warschau gesprochen habe Wochen
nachdem Putin sein würde ich schon
Angriff auf die Ukraine gestartet hatte
und der größte
Landkrieg seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in
Europa begonnen hatte all das was über
75 Jahre
Grundlage für Wohlergehen und Sicherheit
war wurde
geferdet vor einem Jahr hatte die Welt
gedacht
wurde fallen aber ich komme gerade aus
Kiel und ich sage
da steht Stol
und wichtiger noch als alles andere Kiew
ist nach wie vor frei
die russische Invasion stellte nicht nur
die Ukraine auf die Probe sondern die
ganz Welt Europa
Amerika die NATO alle Demokratien
und wir standen vor einer einfachen aber
tiefgründigen Frage würden wir reagieren
oder wegschauen würden wir stark sein
oder schwach würden wir geeint da stehen
oder würden wir gespalten sein aber ein
Jahr später kennen wir alle die Antwort
wir haben reagiert wir waren stark und
wir waren geschlossen und die Welt hat
nicht weggeschaut
wir stehen auch vor grundlegenden Fragen
was das Engagement
zu unseren Werten anbelangte stehen wir
ein für die Souveränität der Nationen
stehen wir ein für das Recht der
Menschen frei von ergression zu leben
stehen wir ein für die Demokratie ein
Jahr später wissen wir wie die Antwort
lauten ja wir stehen ein für die
Souveränität für das Recht der Menschen
frei von Aggressionen zu leben und wir
haben uns ausgesprochen für die
Demokratie und gestern habe ich zusammen
mit Präsidentin in Kiefer vor dem Podium
gestanden und bekräftigt dass wir auch
weiterhin Einstehen für diese selben
Dinge komme was da wolle als Präsident
Putin seine Panzer in die Ukraine
beorderte hat er gedacht er würde das
Land überrollen er
sie sich das ukraische Volk ist einfach
zu mutig Europa Amerika
die
Staaten der stadtlantiks und Pazifiks
waren geschlossen die Demokratie war zu
stark und er konnte nicht diesen
leichten Sieg einfahren sondern seine
Panzer wurden zerstört und brannten aus
er dachte er könnte die NATO Finnland
die Serien aber stattdessen hat er die
naturisierung von Finnland und Schweden
bekommen
er dachte die NATO sei zersplittert und
gespalten aber stattdessen war die
nahezu geschlossener denn je
er dachte er könnte die Energie als
Waffe nutzen und
Europa Schwächen aber gemeinsam haben
wir dafür gesorgt dass Europa nicht mehr
länger von russischen
Treibstoffen abhängig sehr hat gedacht
er sei stark und die Führer Demokratien
sein Spar schwach aber dann ist ja auf
den eisernen Willen aller gestoßen die
nicht zulassen worden das gewandt die
Welt beherrschte und
Präsident selinski hat Mut bewiesen und
er wurde gestählt in seinem Widerstands
Willen Putin steht heute vor etwas
Wasser vor einem Jahr nicht für möglich
wir hatten die Demokratie in der Welt
ist gestärkt worden sie ist nicht
geschwächt worden die Autogramm der Welt
sind aber schwächer geworden nicht
stärker
denn gerade in diesen Stunden der
Unsicherheit muss man wissen wo
ansteht und man muss auch wissen wer an
seiner Seite steht die Menschen in Polen
wissen das sie wissen dass und sie
wissen das besser als jeder andere hier
in Polen denn das ist es was Solidarität
bedeutet
gegen
Unterdrückung sich zu wenden und
Warschau wurde ja zerstört unter der
eisernen Faust des Kommunismus hat
dieses Land und diese Stadt lange
gelitten und die mutigen
Oppositionellen in Belarus kämpfen heute
für ihre Demokratie das zeigt die
Entschlossenheit der Menschen auch in
Moldau in Freiheit zu leben
[Musik]
und sie wollen ihre Unabhängigkeit
wahren auf dem Weg hin zur EU-Präsident
sandu der kann nicht versichern wir
stehen an ihrer Seite und der Seite des
moldawischen Volkes bitte
Beifall für die Präsidentin und für
Moldau
Putin hat heute keine Zweifel mehr an
der Stärke unter Koalition aber er hat
Zweifel an unserer Ausdauer und
erzweifelt dass wir auch weiterhin die
Ukraine unterstützen und dass die NATO
bleibt aber es steht außer Zweifel
unsere Unterstützung der Ukraine bleibt
unerschütterlich wir werden nie müde
werden und die NATO wird nie zögern
Präsident Putin wird scheitern mit
seiner landname aber die voll
der Wille des organischen Volkes das
Land zu verteidigen wird ob Siegen wir
stehen immer ein für diese Werte und
darum geht es hier es geht um die
Freiheit
das ist die Botschaft die ich gestern
nach Kiew gebracht habe ich habe mich ja
an das Volk der Ukraine gewendet
Präsident selenski hatte ja in dezember
in den USA
Gesagte dieser Kampf wird die Welt
bestimmen und wird bestimmt wie unsere
Kinder und Enkelkinder und deren Kinder
und der Enkelkinder leben werden
es geht ja nicht nur das sagte er um die
Kinder und Enkelkinder in der Ukraine
sondern um alle weltweit und heute
erleben wir das auch hier in Polen wir
erleben das in Europa immer wieder
der Appetit der Autokraten den kann man
nicht beschwichtigen dagegen muss man
sich wenden die Autokraten dieser Welt
verstehen nur ein Wort nein nein nein
nein nein
ihr bekommt mein Land nicht ihr bekommt
meine Freiheit nicht ihr kriegt meine
Zukunft nicht und ich wiederhole das was
ich letztes Jahr hier gesagt habe ein
Diktator der ein Empire wieder aufbauen
will wird niemals in der Lage sein das
Streben nach Freiheit der Menschen zu
unterdrücken den Willen der freien und
die Ukraine wird niemals ein Opfer
Russlands werden und Russland wird dort
nie siegen
denn freie Menschen weigern sich in
einer Welt der Dunkelheit und
Hoffnungslosigkeit zu leben das war
wirklich ein außergewöhnliches Jahr in
jeglicher Hinsicht außerordentliche
beurteilität durch russische Söldner und
Streitkräfte sie haben fürchterliche
Dinge begangen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit und das schamlos sie
haben Zivilisten bedroht sie haben
Menschen vergewaltigt sie haben
ukrainische Kinder gestohlen
um die Zukunft der Ukraine zu stehen man
hat zwei weißen Häuser bombardiert
Schulen
bildungseinrichten
Einrichtungen niemand kann seinen Blick
abwenden von diesen Scheußlichkeiten die
Russland gegen das ukrainische Volk
begangen hat und begeht es ist wirklich
fürchterlich
außerordentlich war aber auch die
Reaktion des ukrainischen Volkes und der
Welt ein Jahr nachdem die Bomben auf das
Land niedergingen und russische Panzer
ins Land ist die Ukraine nach wie vor
unabhängig und frei
[Musik]
sondern bis
haben und keine Kämpfer wieder
Territorium sich angeeignet in diesen
Gebieten weht wieder stolz die gelb
Blaue Flagge Präsident selenski steht an
der Spitze einer Regierung die den
Willen des organischen Volkes wiedergibt
auch die Generalversammlung der UNO und
die Welt hat immer wieder die Aggression
Russlands verurteilt
[Musik]
das letzte Mal war die Abstimmung in der
UNO überwältigend im Oktober haben 100
143 Länder die russische Aggression
verurteilt nur vier vier Länder weltweit
standen an der Seite von Russland und
ich wende mich jetzt noch einmal an das
russische Volk die USA und den Nationen
Europas und wollen Russland nicht
kontrollieren sie wollen Russland nicht
zerstören der Westen plant nicht
Russland anzugreifen so wie das Putin
heute gesagt hat und Millionen von
russischen Bürgern wollen nur in Frieden
mit ihren Nachbarn leben und die sind
nicht unser Gegner dieser Krieg war nie
eine Notwendigkeit er ist eine Tragödie
Präsident Putin hat sich für den Krieg
entschieden und jeden Tag den der Krieg
anhält das ist die Entscheidung Putins
er könnte den Krieg beenden wenn
Russland mit Invasion in der Ukraine
aufhört würde der Krieg beendet werden
wenn die Ukraine aufhört zu kämpfen dann
wäre dass das Ende der Ukraine deshalb
müssen wir alle zusammen sicherstellen
dass die Ukraine sich selbst verteidigen
kann
die USA hat eine weltweite Koalition von
mehr als 50 Nationen geschmiedet um
kritische Waffen und Gerät den mutigen
Soldaten in der Ukraine zu lieben
luftabwehrartillerie Panzer gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge die Europäische Union und ihre
Mitgliedstaaten haben wirklich
ungeheures geleistet nicht nur Endpunkt
für sicherheitshilfe sondern auch
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre
Unterstützung Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen
und alle hier heute Abend sollten mal
kurz innerhalb und das meine ich
wirklich schauen Sie sich um schauen sie
einander an und betrachten Sie was Sie
bisher gemacht haben in Polen wurden
mehr als 1,5 Millionen Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen gott segne sie dafür
den Großzügigkeit Polens die
Bereitschaft die Herzen und Häuser zu
öffnen suchen ihresgleichen überall in
meinem Land in großen Städten und in
kleinen Städten
Wehen die ukrainischen Flaggen und im
letzten Jahr haben die Demokraten und
Republikaner im amerikanischen Kongress
gemeinsam für den Frieden plädiert sich
dafür eingesetzt so sind die Amerikaner
und das machen wir Amerikaner die Welt
kommt auch zusammen um die weltweiten
Folgen von Putins Kriege zu begegnen
Putin hat dafür gesorgt dass die Hilfe
im Schwarzen Meer geschlossen waren
damit die Ukraine Getreide nicht
exportieren können dadurch wurde eine
weltweite Lebensmittelkrise an geheizt
gerade Afrika ist davon besonders
betroffen die USA und die G7 und Partner
weltweite haben stattdessen sich
eingesetzt um die weltweite
Nahrungsmittel Versorgung wieder zu
stärken und meine Frau JüL bei den reist
in dieser Woche nach Afrika um unsere
Unterstützung auch dort zu bekunden wir
setzen uns ein für das Volk der Ukraine
für die Zukunft der Ukraine eine Ukraine
die frei souverän und demokratisch ist
das war der Traum derjenigen die vor
mehr als 30 Jahren die Unabhängigkeit
der Ukraine begründet haben die die
Revolution der wurde gestartet haben die
auf dem Maidan sich eingesetzt haben für
die Demokratie und hunderte haben dort
ihr Leben gelassen trotzdem versucht
Putin weiter hier hin andere zu
korrumpieren
ein Traum der ukrainischen Patrioten die
über Jahre hinweg sich gegen die
russische Aggression im
dornbasiert haben und diejenigen die
eher die Leben gegeben haben für ihre
geliebte Heimat Ukraine ich habe gestern
am Kriegerdenkmal ein Kranz niedergelegt
und derer gedacht die ihr Leben gelassen
haben an der Seite von Präsident silency
die USA und unsere Partner stehen an der
Seite der Lehrer der Ersthelfer der
Arbeitnehmer der Kommunen überall in der
Ukraine die versuchen den Strom
wiederherzustellen angesichts der
grausamen Bombardierung durch Russland
wir stehen an der Seite von Millionen
von Flüchtlingen die aufgenommen wurden
in Europa in den USA aber insbesondere
hier in Polen ganz gewöhnliche Menschen
in Europa waren bereit zu helfen und
helfen auch weiterhin die Wirtschaft die
kulturellen Führer und die Fürst lad von
Polen haben mit Herz und
Entschlossenheit geholfen und haben
gezeigt was das gute ist
wir danken der First Lady und wir
Gedanken der gesamten Bevölkerung ich
werde nicht dran
vergessen dass ich im letzten Jahr die
ersten ukrainischen Flüchtlinge gesehen
habe ich habe ihnen ihre Gesichter
geschaut sie waren verzweifelt sie haben
ihre Kinder eng an sich gedrückt und
wussten nicht ob sie ihre Brüder und
Cousins wiedersehen würden und in dieser
dunkelsten Stunde haben sie den
Flüchtlingen Sicherheit und Unterkunft
geboten sie haben sie umarmen sie haben
sie aufgenommen und in der Zwischenzeit
haben wir zusammen dafür gesorgt dass
Russland den Preis zahlt wir haben die
umfassendsten Sanktionen erlassen die
ist je gab und wir werden in dieser
Woche noch weitere Sanktionen zusammen
mit unseren Partnern verkündet und wir
werden diejenigen zur Rechenschaft
ziehen die für diesen Krieg
verantwortlich sind und wir werden alle
die Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit begonnen haben
zur Rechenschaft ziehen
es gibt so vieles auf dass wir stolz
sein können die Dinge die wir im letzten
Jahr gemeinsam erreicht haben wir müssen
müssen wirklich
offenen Auges in die Dinge schauen die
Freiheit zu verteidigen da geht es nicht
um einen Tag oder ein paar Wochen es ist
immer schwer es dauert lange und die
Ukraine verteidigt sich weiterhin selbst
gegen die russischen Attacken
und sie es wird auch weiterhin bittere
Tage geben
Tage die
Opfer fordern und Tragödien aber die
Vereinigten Staaten stehen gemeinsam mit
den Partnern hinter der Ukraine während
dieses Land sich selbst verteidigt im
nächsten Jahr werde ich eine Versammlung
der NATO einberufen für den Gipfel
wir werden den 50 den 75 jahrestag der
NATO feiern dieser starken Vereinigung
und es gibt keinen Zweifel die USA steht
hinter der NATO und steht als Partner
bei der Nate und jeder jedes Mitglied in
der NATO weiß dass Russland weiß das
genau so ein Angriff auf einem an einem
Mitglied der NATO ist ein Angriff auf
alle NATO Mitglieder wir werden jeden
Zentimeter des Territoriums der NATO
verteidigen im letzten Jahr hat die USA
sich mehrfach mit den Partnern getroffen
um dieses starke Koalition aufzubauen
gegen die Aggression der Russen
und darum geht es dabei geht es nicht
nur um die Dinge gegen die wir sehen
sondern Dinge für die wir sind in
welcher Welt möchten wir leben wir
müssen das strategisch angehen die
Koalition nutzen um den Menschen ein
besseres Leben zu geben mehr Gesundheit
mehr Wohlbefinden wir müssen Frieden und
Sicherheit aufbauen und jeden Menschen
Würde und Freiheit zu Teil werden können
damit allen Freiheit zu Teil werden kann
wir sind an einem Wendepunkt
die Entscheidung die wir in den nächsten
fünf Jahren treffen die werden
entscheidende Bedeutung haben für die
nächsten
Jahrzehnte unseres Lebens das gilt für
die Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner was
gilt für die Menschen in der ganzen Welt
die Entscheidung die jetzt gefällt
werden da geht es entscheidend um unsere
Zukunft Chaos oder Stabilität aufbauen
oder zerstören Hoffnung oder Angst
Demokratie
Hoffnung oder Diktatur unzerstörung
durch Diktatoren Begrenzung oder
Möglichkeiten
Möglichkeiten eröffnen sich wenn
Menschen in Freiheit leben nicht in
Gefangenschaft Freiheit Freiheit es gibt
kein wunderbares Wort als Freiheit es
gibt kein Terroristen Ziel als Frieden
die Amerikaner wissen das und sie alle
wissen das genauso
und all das was wir jetzt tun muss getan
werden damit unsere Kinder und
Kindeskinder auch diese Erfahrung machen
Freiheit
Freiheit ist die Wahrheit aller
Zeitalter
wir werden für sie einstehen stehen sie
für uns ein gehen wir also in die
Zukunft mit Überzeugung mit Hoffnung wir
sind Verbündete Verbündete des Lichtes
nicht der Dunkelheit nicht der
Unterdrückung sondern der Freiheit nicht
der Gefangenschaft sondern Verbündete ja
der Freiheit möge Gott sie alle segnen
schützen möge Gott unsere Truppen
schützen und möge Gott die Ukraine
schützen und segnen und all diejenigen
die den Frieden in der ganzen Welt
verteidigen danke Polen danke Danke
Danke für all das was sie tun gott
schütze sie alle
[Musik]
so und soweit also die Rede die ich
Ansprache des US-Präsidenten war gar
nicht so lange wie man vielleicht hätte
denken können 15 20 Minuten in etwa nach
meiner inoffiziellen stoppung fassen wir
vielleicht ganz kurz die wichtigsten
Punkte zusammen bevor wir dann gleich
mit MRT wissen noch mal einige Punkte
dann auch in einzelnen betrachten wollen
also es war eine ziemlich emotionale
Rede wir waren stark sagte Präsident
beiden geschlossen und haben nicht
weggeschaut als die Ukraine überfallen
wurde auch ein Jahr nach dem Angriff
Russlands steht die USA stehen die USA
für das Recht einen Frieden und Freiheit
zu leben Putin wollte die NATO spalten
aber das ist ihm nicht gelungen sie ist
nun geschlossener denn je viel Lob gab
es für den heldenhaften Kampf der
Ukraine und auch noch mal den Hinweis
dass die UN den Krieg also verurteilt
habe damals insgesamt wenn man sich
natürlich auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte wenn man so will nicht der
Westen ist der Aggressor sondern
Russland Putin könne den Krieg stoppen
die Ukraine eben nicht und dann gab es
auch noch ein klares Bekenntnis zur NATO
außerdem die Welt steht am Scheideweg
darüber kann man vielleicht gleich auch
noch mit MRT Wissen sprechen die
nächsten fünf Jahre sein entscheidend
hört er uns denn schon wäre jetzt meine
Frage
da sehen wir ihn jetzt hat er auch
wieder Licht drin musste er das Licht
ausknipsen aus Sicherheitsgründen also
immer wie hat die Rede auf dich gewirkt
gab es aus deiner Sicht überraschendes
deckte sie sich in etwa mit deinen
Erwartungen
[Musik]
ehrlich gesagt war die Rede ein Stück
weit kleiner als die vor einem Jahr er
hat nicht das ganz groß
vor allen Dingen an die Geschichte
erinnert an die Geschichte des Zweiten
Weltkriegs an die Geschichte der
Befreiung Polens in der
solidarischbewegung und der Revolution
hier in Polen das hat er diesmal in
diesem Ausmaß nicht getan ich glaube er
wollte sich auf drei Punkte
konzentrieren der erste Punkt Autokraten
verstehen ist nur wenn man Nein sagt man
muss sich ihnen entgegenstellen nur
diese Botschaft verstehen sie der zweite
Punkt Freiheit freiheit ist das
allerwichtigste das ist ein Begriff der
hier in Osteuropa besonders in Polen
aber auch in anderen aus der
europäischen Ländern sehr sehr gut
ankommt weil man eben weiß dass die
Freiheit nicht kostenlos zu kriegen ist
dass man dafür etwas einsetzen muss und
das dritte das hat mir heute morgen
schon einmal vor dem nationalen
Sicherheitsberater Jake Sullivan gehört
dass er klar gemacht hat Wladimir Putin
könnte im Grunde genommen so wie er
hat auch diesen Krieg sehr sehr einfach
beenden indem er eben die Truppen
abzieht aus der Ukraine die Ukraine kann
sich nicht erlauben das Kämpfen
einzustellen weil dann gäbe es eben die
Ukraine nicht mehr diese drei glaube ich
großen Botschaften die wollte er hier
rüberbringen weil es sehr wichtig ist
dass die Allianz die Verbündeten die
Bündnisse hier weiterhin geschlossen
bleiben denn der amerikanische
nächsten Wochen die Ukraine noch ein
Stück weit stärker zu unterstützen so
hören wir also auch weitreichende
Raketen zu liefern um sicherzustellen
dass die Ukraine auch weiter Territorium
zurückerobern kann das Ziel ist dabei
dass man Putin in eine Situation bringt
wo auch Russland einen Interesse daran
hat zu einem verhandlungsfrieden zu
kommen aber das geht eben nur wenn Putin
erst einmal bereit wäre ein Stück weit
von seinen maximalen Zielen
das ist nicht in Sicht wir haben das
gerade aus Moskau heute gehört aber ja
Joe Biden will hier die Botschaft
hinterlassen man steht geeint hinter der
Ukraine und ist Polen auch sehr sehr
dankbar für die Unterstützung
ihr habt das gesehen Liebe Userinnen und
User Liebe ZuschauerInnen wir haben ab
und zu einen leichtes Ton bzw
bildproblem immer wir versuchen
vielleicht trotzdem gerade noch mal eine
Frage nach Polen zu stellen das meiste
kam bei uns gut an vielleicht noch mal
kurz zur Einordnung wie ist das mit dem
Scheideweg gemeint gewesen da ging
beiden am Ende seiner Rede drauf ein die
nächsten fünf Jahre oder so sagte er
seinen entscheiden sowohl in Europa als
auch in den USA vielleicht kann man das
noch ein bisschen weiter ausführen was
was ist damit gemeint
ja der Präsident malcha immer dieses
Bild von großen Kampf zwischen den
liberalen Demokratien auf der einen
Seite und den autoritären Regimen auf
der anderen Seite und er glaubt in der
Tat daran dass das ein Scheideweg ist an
dem die Welt steht und sich entscheiden
muss ist sie für die regelbasierte
Ordnung so wie wir sie seit Jahrzehnten
kennen eine Ordnung die für Freiheit die
aber auch für demokratische Werte auch
für Bürger und Menschenrechte steht oder
geht die Welt in eine Richtung die
autoritärer ist wo individuelle
Freiheiten nicht so wichtig sind das
sind Prinzipien für die China und auch
Russland stehen also im Grunde genommen
Präsident meint damit auch ein Stück
weit die Europäer aber auch die USA
selber weil wir haben in Europa aber
auch in den USA erlebt dass diese
Demokratien von innen unter Beschuss
sind ich
war 2021 den Sturm aus Kapitol er sich
sehr wohl bewusst dass diese Demokratie
auch fragil sein kann deswegen hat er
eine
Politik steht unter Druck zu liefern sie
muss ihren Menschen auch Perspektiven
bieten und beweisen dass Demokratie
besser ist als Autoritarismus
am Schloss in Warschau vielen Dank wie
gesagt wir hätten leichte Probleme mit
dem Ton und auch mit dem Bild da ist
einfach gerade wahnsinnig viel los bei
dir da sind die Leitungen überlastet
danke schön für diese Einschätzungen und
Informationen danke nachholen el MRT
wissen so wir gucken dass wir vielleicht
das Gespräch fortführen mit Maximilian
der Halle wenn das möglich ist falls der
mich auch noch hören kann in Berlin ich
glaube ich sehe ihn und ich hoffe auch
er hört mich er hätte alle schön dass
Sie bei uns sind Politikwissenschaftler
an der London School of Economics and
political science vielleicht gerade auch
noch mal ihre allgemeine Einschätzung zu
Rede von Präsident beiden wie hat diese
auf sie gewirkt
ja das war ja eine wichtige
friedensrede die die Polen darin
bestärken soll an die NATO die sie
schützt zu glauben und das vorgetragen
von dem Repräsentanten der macht die das
verbürgen kann und ich glaube da in
dieser Rede da sollte man nicht zu
schnell zu viel Pathos hinein reden
sondern das was beiden hier sagt das
meint der ganz ernst nämlich dass
Freiheit nicht dauerhaft umsonst zu
haben ist sondern dass dafür zwei auch
gekämpft werden muss und ich glaube
diese Botschaft die kommt bei den Polen
natürlich gut an weil sie sich bestärkt
fühlen in der Richtigkeit ihres Kurses
aber natürlich auch in Richtung Ukraine
die Ukraine noch mal darin bestärkt dass
der Kampf den sie führen eben notwendig
ist aber auch ein Ruf hinein in die NATO
nicht auch vielleicht sogar bis nach
nach Deutschland hier sich noch einmal
genau das vergewissern um was es
wirklich geht nämlich die rückdrängung
eines Aggressors der ansonsten das was
wir als Freiheit bezeichnen sehr stark
beschneiden würde wenn ich beenden würde
es war ja auch eine Replik auf die
früher am Tag gehalten Rede des
russischen Präsidenten Wladimir Putin
und beiden hat ja unter anderem auch
gesagt die Ukraine wird nie ein Sieg für
Russland werden also wie kann man das
jetzt einschätzen wie werden diese Worte
in Russland ankommen denn in Russland
hatte man ja also bzw nach der Rede den
Eindruck dass man sich dort ohnehin auch
auf eine lange Auseinandersetzung
einstellt unnachgiebig beide Seiten
zuerst Russland jetzt eben auch die USA
worauf läuft das hinaus
naja in erster Linie hat beiden ja noch
einmal verdeutlicht vor der vor dem
Hintergrund der Rede von Putins dass das
was Putin erreicht sind wollte bisher
nämlich Teilung des Westens keine
Durchhaltefähigkeit des Westens bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine
all das hat nichts funktioniert auch die
Umstellung der Militär Taktik auf
Bombardierung der
zivilenzentren Zerstörung der der
Versorgung mit Energie Elektrizität etc
all das hat nicht funktioniert und ich
glaube was das unterstreicht ist
letztlich etwas was ganz entscheidend
werden könnte nämlich neben dem
materiellen militärischen die schiere
Wille für die eigenen Werte kämpfen zu
wollen auf der Seite der Ukraine und auf
der anderen Seite steht Russland bei dem
vielleicht nicht jeder Soldat weiß warum
er eigentlich das tut was er gegenwärtig
tut und dieses gar nicht als pathetisch
anzumahnen weil meine Erinnerung zu
rufen ich glaube wichtig um die
Glaubwürdigkeit und darum geht es aus
militärischer Sicht und die
Glaubwürdigkeit der NATO in diese
Richtung dauerhaft zu unterstreichen das
der Westen an der Seite der Ukraine
steht
lau bin Lee schreibt uns über Youtube
beide reden helfen nicht den Krieg zu
beenden tja das ist natürlich jetzt so
die Sache haben Sie irgendwelche
Ansatzpunkte heraushören lesen können
aus einer der beiden reden wo man sagen
könnte da besteht eventuell eine
ansatzmöglichkeit diplomatische
Beziehungen wieder irgendwie zu
intensivieren auf den ersten Eindruck
hin muss man ja sagen klingt es auf
beiden Seiten überhaupt nicht so
naja also wir sind hier nicht in einer
üblichen Verhandlungen zwischen zwei
Tarifpartnern sondern wie geht es ja
darum dass jemand militärische Gewalt
benutzt um etwas zu holen was ihm nicht
gehört
und hier jetzt ein verhandlungsstisch zu
sehen an dem man sich gegebenenfalls
setzen könnte da müssen einige
Bedingungen geschafft werden und
gegenwärtig sieht es nicht so aus dass
die russische Seite auch nur ein
Millimeter seine Aggression zurücknehmen
will und entsprechend ist der Wille der
Ukrainer genauso bedingungslos ich
glaube aber hier noch mal ganz klar zu
erkennen nicht wer der Gresser ist und
wer der Verteidiger das eigenen der
eigenen Freiheit ist das ist ganz
wichtig um nicht den Fehler zu machen
dass beide eigentlich gleich an diesem
an diesem Wettkampf beteiligt sind nein
das ist Krieg ja der auch eine
eindeutige Verantwortlichkeit hat das
wollten wir jetzt damit nicht den Abrede
stellen ganz klar wir fragen noch mal
mit oko Youtube heißt der wohl an
Professor Thale welche Reaktion wäre vom
Westen zu erwarten sollte sich Russland
für den Einsatz eines atomaren Anschlags
entscheiden also von atomaren Schlägen
ist jetzt zum Glück momentan nur
theoretisch die Rede sie halten es
hatten Film auch schon gesagt für wenig
wahrscheinlich das zu diesem Mittel
gegriffen
würde zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt
den Schritt den Putin jetzt gemacht hat
den new startvertrag zu suspendieren
unilateral das ist ein machtpolitischer
Ansatz um zu sagen hört zu seh zu ich
werde diese Regulierung Begrenzung den
klaren Sprengköpfe nicht zwingend
einhalten damit setzt er ein klares
Signal oder will ein Signal richtig in
Richtung Westen schicken ich bin
kampfbereit um daraus das ist ja das
Prinzip Einschüchterung was in Teilen
sehr gut funktioniert hat mit dem
Prinzip Einschüchterung zu versuchen im
Westen diejenigen die vielleicht sich
doch aus der Einheit herausbrechen
lassen die eben herauszubrechen das ist
der erste Punkt das ist der zentrale
Punkt deshalb Putin das macht das zweite
ein tatsächlicher nukleare Angriff
der passiert nicht aus der hohen Hand da
gibt es ein Vorfeld zu und das Vorfeld
das hatten wir in viel kleineren Format
Ende letzten Jahres also September
Oktober als Amerikaner und Russen sehr
deutlich über die Thematik gesprochen
hatten nachdem Putin den Androhung von
als taktischen Nuklearschlag innerhalb
der Ukraine erwogen hat darauf gab es
sehr sehr deutsche Auseinandersetzung
zwischen den beiden die im Ergebnis
bedeuteten nach 5 Tagen hat Russland
nicht mehr über die Thematik gesprochen
also ich würde auch hier das erste
Prinzip noch mal im Vordergrund stellen
es ist die
einschüchterungspolitik die hinter der
Androhung aus dem startvertrag
auszutreten steht die die möglichen
Akteure im Westen erreichen soll damit
Sie die Position der NATO an sich nicht
mehr mittragen das ist der der Ansatz
hier geht es nicht um einen direkte
militärische nukleare Konfrontation
mit Verstand fragt uns was müsste getan
werden um einen weiteren Kalten Krieg zu
verhindern vielleicht manchmal etwas
auch allgemeiner gefragt sehen Sie denn
irgendwo eine Exit-Strategie wie gesagt
sie hatten vorhin schon gesagt da gibt
es eine klare Verantwortung ganz klar
aber gibt es für sie trotzdem irgendwie
eine Möglichkeit zu sagen naja so oder
so könnte irgendwann das Blut vergießen
beendet werden kann das nur aus Russland
kommen was müsste in Russland dafür
passieren dass dieser Zeitpunkt
irgendwann mal kommt also ich das geht
genau in diese Richtung was passieren
muss ist das
bedauerlicherweise auf dem Schlachtfeld
entschieden wird wer der Sieger dieses
Krieges ist und umso mehr Niederlagen
Russland gegebenenfalls in Russland in
das kleine er fährt in den nächsten
Monaten wir werden die offensiven die
jetzt kommen sehr genau beobachten
können umso mehr Niederlagen ist ein
Pferd umso größer wird der Widerstand
innerhalb Russlands werden diesen Krieg
weiterzuführen also ich habe immer
wieder gemerkt in den Unterhaltung das
Russland angeblich diese ewige
durchhalte Leitfähigkeit besäße ähnlich
wie ein Vaterländischen Krieg im Zweiten
Weltkrieg das ist alles nicht richtig es
geht hier darum einen Krieg den Russland
angefangen hat aus russischer Sicht zu
gewinnen da setzt sich die Ukraine
dagegen und ich glaube umso mehrere
Niederlagen sich häufen umso schwieriger
wird das auch für den angeblich
unschlagbaren Putin sich selber
zurechtfertigen das darf man bei dem
nicht vergessen die ganze Kritik die im
Apparat im Kreml an ihm herrscht wir
hatten vorher den Streit zwischen
regulären Truppen und wagnergruppe all
das geht ja letztlich auf Putin zurück
warum ist der Leitwolf nicht in der Lage
das zu tun worüber er mit Einfachheit
redet und auch das vielleicht zum
Schluss bis heute von einer
spezialoperation redet und nicht vom
Krieg
eine letzte Frage vielleicht noch mal
ein Aspekt den unsere Zuschauer auch
immer wieder mit einbringen die Rolle
Chinas sie hatten vorhin vor der Rede
von beiden schon was dazu gesagt
kommt die Frage als wie wahrscheinlich
ist der militärische Zusammenschluss
Russlands mit China unter unter
Umständen sogar Südafrikas einzuschätzen
wird China eine andere Frage wird China
Soldaten in die Ukraine schicken
vielleicht noch mal zur Rolle Chinas in
diesem Konflikt ja also China wird keine
Soldaten in Russland schicken was an dem
von blinken angedeutetem möglichen
waffentransfer zwischen Chinesen und
Russen passiert das muss man ganz genau
beobachten weil es andeutet wie sich
China orientieren will will es
tatsächlich
durch ölabnahme die Kriegsmaschine rein
Putins mit finanzieren oder wie das
aktiv in diesem Krieg Eingreifen ich
glaube die
Friedensinitiative die jetzt der
außenpolitische höchste außen Vertreter
Chinas wangier in München vor einigen
Tagen genannt hat
die sollte man genau beobachten
natürlich aber bei dem ganzen immer das
Spiegelbild Taiwan sehen natürlich geht
das den Chinesen darum möglichst einer
erfolgreiches ein erfolgreicher
Schablone zu haben die ihren Krieg wann
hier hat es ja in München sehr deutlich
und noch mal unterstrichen das Taiwan
eben sich China gehört die ein möglichen
Krieg gegen Taiwan ebenfalls
rechtfertigt deshalb gehen die Chinesen
die ganze Zeit mit das Russland sicher
nur verteidigt gegen von außen den
Angriff durch die Amerikaner also das
ist das das Vorbild für teilbar insofern
würde ich die vermittlungsrolle oder
auch die friedensrolle die Chinesen hier
macht politisch komplett ausschließen
das Thema wird uns so oder so noch eine
ganze Weile beschäftigen davon ist
leider auszugehen die Einschätzungen von
Maximilian der Halle waren das
Politikwissenschaftler an der London
School of Economics and political
science vielen Dank dass Sie sich die
Zeit heute Abend für uns genommen danke
schön ich Bedanke Michael
so und an euch natürlich auch wie immer
ein herzliches Dankeschön für die
zahlreichen Fragen und Kommentare das
war unser Stream zu den Reden von
russlands Präsident Putin heute
Vormittag und das US-Präsidenten beiden
vorhin danke schön für euer Interesse
einen schönen Abend und bis demnächst
ciao